Charlottesville Virginia has filed a
unique lawsuit trying to prevent future
mass demonstrations in the city that
could result in violence the city argues
that deadly protests by white
supremacists and other groups in August
violated a Virginia law banning private
armies Paula Reid reports
Charlottesville city leaders marched to
the courthouse on Thursday to file a
lawsuit intended to stop future violent
protests like the one that occurred in
August had left one woman dead and
dozens injured the lawsuit relies on a
novel legal theory alleging that the
white supremacists and militia groups
that descended on the city were
violating Virginia statue against
private militias and planning for
violence outside government supervision
the protesters had a permit for the
rally and Virginia is an open carry
state it was not a normal protest what
we saw was really militaries invading
Charlottesville Mary McCord is a former
federal prosecutor and is now a senior
litigator at Georgetown Law she says the
level of organization and an alleged
attempt to intimidate make the August
event different from constitutionally
protected speech
we saw the self-professed militia who
claimed to be there to keep the peace
but they weren't under the authority of
the governor they weren't under the
authority of the National Guard they
were just under their own authority and
that's prohibited in under Virginia law
there are 22 defendants named in the
lawsuit we reached out to all of them
but none would agree to an on-camera
interview but some have taken to social
media to respond Christian yang Ling the
commanding officer of the Pennsylvania
lightfoot militia wrote on Facebook our
team acted strictly as a neutral
peacekeeping force and did not take
sides in any fashion we helped people on
both sides while we were repeatedly
assaulted by both sides the lawsuit
alleges at Virginia's ban on private
militias also extends to peacekeeping
efforts wearing matching shirts merit
wearing matching hats is fine that's
protected freedom of expression but what
we think is not protected and more
importantly is in direct violation of
Virginia's statutes and constitution is
this paramilitary activity protesters
argue the government cannot
regulate all right activists who carry
shields and flag poles to rallies and
not regulate leftists who do the same
thing but the city's attorneys say if
this is successful it could be used as a
tool by dozens of states to block
paramilitary activity across the
political spectrum Paula Reid in our
Washington bureau thanks